Okay, so now you have an image.
Now what?
This is where Vagrant comes in.
The tagland for Vagrant is
development environments made easy.
And, that's what we want it to have,
right.
Vagrant allows you to create, run and
connect to development
environments in a very easy way.
We've provided a configuration file for
Vagrant or a Vagrant file.
For convenience it's in
the virtual box directory,
where packers saved its artifact.
You just have to register with Vagrant
the artifact that you just created.
You can do that with
the Vagrant box add command.
You just specify name parameter.
Which I'm just having
be devops-appserver.
Now that it's successfully added,
since there's a vagrant
file in this directory.
You can do vagrant up, and
it will bring up the dev environment.
It'll also mount shared folders, so you
can easily use your favorite editor or
IDE for for development.
By default, only the host's
current directory share to
the target/vagrant directory.
But, we have provided some
additional configuration.
And once the machine is up,
you can type vagrant ssh to log into it.